hello everyone my name is Vash I work
for a company that hires a lot of shiny
developers across the globe in one of
those markers in the southern part of
India you'll find me sitting in front of
my computer building some shiny apps and
programming with r while occasionally
interviewing people to join our
team last year over 1200 applicants
applied for the our shiny developer role
at Epsilon and we hired over 30 shiny
developers that year the volume of these
candidates has helped us understand what
to look for in a shiny developer and
I'll be sharing some tips on how you can
become a better shiny
developer you might call yourself a data
scientist analyst bio statistician or
any of the hundreds of titles that use
RN shiny but as soon as you've built
your first shiny app you're a software
developer we've noticed that many of the
applicants would greatly benefit from
following some good software development
practices for
example can you tell what will be the
output of
this if well written you can easily do
that how about
now it produces the same output as
before even the functions do the same
thing as before but I hope it explains
one of the many ideas about writing code
that is
maintainable but all the other ideas are
just as simple as this one it's many
small things like these that make up a
good
developer let's imagine that you're
working in one of our shiny apps from
our Gallery called future forests this
app allows you to visualize the future
Forest distributions of 12 species under
four
scenarios the data source for this app
is just a bunch of RDS files with some
cryptic names but the names are not that
cryptic once you know what they
represent the prefix of the file name
corresponds to a scientific name while
the suffix of the file name corresponds
to one of those
scenarios let's say you accidentally
delete one of these files now you should
get an error for a very specific
selection in the app while the rest of
the app works just fine so you don't
realize that you have an error until
someone complains about
it but now imagine that you have an R
script where you check for the existence
of a data file for every combinations of
Ed by the app it should give you an
error when some file is missing this is
what we call a unit test and trust me
this will save you from an embarrassment
of disconnected from server I know we've
all been there you can easily write test
like these using test that and shiny
Test
2 if you check out the function
references for shiny you'll find over
250 functions listed over there this can
be overwhelming if you're just getting
started with shiny but I will would
highly recommend to go through the
functions related to reactive
programming reactive programming is the
core concept of shiny that differentiate
it from other Frameworks again this
seems like a lot of functions but not
really because the input output and
render functions all behave the
same again these functions can be
grouped into one of these three shapes
based on where they they are used in the
logic Source conductor or
endpoint you just need to remember three
rules while working with these reactive
functions the shape determines how they
can connect with each other you can
connect as many reactive components as
you want finally you can also have many
to many connections with them the
simpler you make the reactive
connections the easier it would be for a
human to interpret it and for shiny to
perform fewer computations to get things
done finally I recommend going through
the software engineering key skills uh
sheet that we internally uh created to
improve
the
sorry finally I want to highlight a
valuable resource that we uh consider it
greatly contribute to our team's
technical growth the software
engineering key skill sheet we've put a
lot of effort in building this and we
maintain it regularly this has been
instrumental in gu guiding hundreds of
shiny developers towards their
professional development goals and I I
hope this would help you find topics and
resources as
well thank you so much for your
attention and you can find me in the
absolon booth if you have any
[Applause]
questions